From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm David Kestenbaum, sitting in for Ira Glass. And I'm just going to let my first two guests today introduce themselves.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆，代班主持人艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我打算让我的前两位嘉宾先自我介绍一下。
My name is Gary Powell. I'm a stunt coordinator, second unit director in motion films.
我叫加里·鲍威尔。我是电影行业的特技协调员和第二摄制组导演。
Name a couple movies.
列举几部电影吧。
Oh, Titanic, James Bond, Mission Impossible.
哦，《泰坦尼克号》、《007》系列、《碟中谍》。
OK, Miles, your turn.
好的，迈尔斯，轮到你了。
I don't have a job.
我没有工作。
You could say your name, though.
不过，你可以说出你的名字。
Miles.
迈尔斯。
Miles is 7-- well, almost 7. And we arranged for him to talk to Gary because he had some urgent questions about car chases from movies. And Gary? That's his particular set of skills.
迈尔斯7岁——好吧，快7岁了。我们安排他与加里谈话，因为他对电影里的汽车追逐戏有一些迫切的问题。而加里，这正是他的专长所在。
I drove the crane in Terminator, the bus in Harry Potter.
我开过《终结者》里的起重机，《哈利·波特》里的公共汽车。
What, you drove the bus in Harry Potter?
什么，你开过《哈利·波特》里的公共汽车？
I did.
是的。
A little background-- Miles loves cars. His mom says that before he could read, he could tell you make and model and sometimes year of any of their friends' cars. He draws cars, makes cars out of LEGOs. He brought one with him, actually. And he and Gary quickly got down to talking shop.
背景介绍一下——迈尔斯酷爱汽车。他妈妈说，在他还没学会认字之前，他就能认出朋友车子的品牌、型号，有时甚至是年份。他喜欢画车，用乐高拼车。其实他今天也带来了一辆。他和加里很快就开始聊起了行家里手的话题。
I do car chases with my seven and eight cars.
我用我那七八辆小车玩汽车追逐游戏。
Right. So do you choreograph little car chases for yourself then?
没错。那你平时会为自己编排一些小的追逐戏吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That's cool. Do you know what you should do?
那太酷了。你知道你应该怎么做吗？
Before this conversation with Gary, Miles showed me this one kind of amazing drawing he'd done. It's a scene from a particular movie. He's drawn what looks like a black police car in the air, flying backward over a second car. Miles would tell you the second car is a Ford Pinto. Miles hasn't seen the actual movie this is from, just this scene, over and over.
在与加里的谈话开始前，迈尔斯给我看了一张他画的了不起的画。那是特定电影里的一个场景。他画了一辆看起来像是在空中的黑色警车，正从另一辆车上方翻飞过去。迈尔斯会告诉你，那第二辆车是福特平托（Ford Pinto）。迈尔斯其实没看过这部电影，只是反复看这个片段。
Have you watched the Blues Brothers car chase that's eight minutes long?
你看过那场长达八分钟的《福禄双霸天》汽车追逐戏吗？
Yes, I have.
看过。
Have you seen the backwards flip?
你看到那个向后翻转的镜头了吗？
The one at the end?
结尾那个？
Yeah.
对。
看过。
That's a picture of it.
那张画的就是这个。
This is the thing he had questions about-- the famous car chase at the end of The Blues Brothers. The whole thing is actually 11 minutes long.
这就是他一直想问的问题——《福禄双霸天》结尾那场著名的汽车追逐戏。整场戏实际上有11分钟长。
I remember the first time I saw it, I fell over.
我记得第一次看的时候，我直接惊呆了。
Because it was so amazing?
是因为它太精彩了吗？
I mean, like, are those people billionaires if they can buy 150 Dodge police cars, only to crash them?
我是说，他们是不是亿万富翁啊，能买150辆道奇警车就为了撞毁它们？
If you haven't seen the movie, it's a ridiculous, massive smash-up of cars. Miles had questions about how it was all done, and Gary Powell, world expert on car chases, said he was happy to help.
如果你没看过这部电影，那是一场荒谬且壮观的连环车祸。迈尔斯对这一切是如何完成的充满疑问，而汽车追逐戏的世界专家加里·鲍威尔表示很乐意提供帮助。
Hey, Miles, should we just play through it? And whenever that you have a question, you just say, stop.
嘿，迈尔斯，我们要不直接放来看看？只要你有问题，就喊“停”。
All right.
没问题。
All right, here we are, the final car chase scene in The Blues Brothers.
好了，现在到了《福禄双霸天》最后的汽车追逐戏了。
Let's go.
开始吧。
I'll narrate for you. It starts with the Blues brothers, sunglasses, black suits, driving an old beat-up black cop car that they bought used. It's their single car being pursued on the highway by a long line of police cars.
我来为你讲解。影片开始是布鲁斯兄弟，戴着墨镜，穿着黑色西装，开着他们买的二手破旧黑色警车。他们在高速公路上被一长串警车追逐。
Officers are in pursuit. A black and white 1974 Dodge sedan--
警察正在追捕。一辆黑白相间的1974年道奇轿车——
Pause. Pause. Are those Nazis real Nazis?
暂停。暂停。那些纳粹是真的纳粹吗？
He's talking here about members of the Illinois Nazi party who join the car chase in an orange Ford Pinto.
他问的是伊利诺伊州纳粹党的成员，他们开着一辆橙色的福特平托加入了追逐。
Are those Nazis real Nazis?
那些纳粹是真的纳粹吗？
No, they'll be actors playing those parts.
不，那是演员在扮演那些角色。
Oh.
哦。
Miles is like, good to know. We move on to the action. Chase continues.
迈尔斯点点头，表示知道了。我们继续看动作戏。追逐继续。
I got to pull over.
我得靠边停车。
Dan Aykroyd drives right through a highway barrier and down the embankment. They continue OK, but the cop car behind them crashes, followed by the one behind them and the next one, some upside down. It goes on quite a while.
丹·艾克罗伊德直接撞开了高速公路的护栏，冲下了堤岸。他们继续前进，但身后的警车撞毁了，紧接着后边的车也撞了，还有后面的，有的甚至翻了过来。这持续了很长时间。
[CRASHING]
[撞击声]
Pause. Pause.
暂停。暂停。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
Do they actually-- are the people OK in the cars when they crash? Like, are there people in there, like real people who are--
他们真的……撞车时车里的人没事吗？我是说，里面有人吗，那些是真人吗？
Yes, there is. There'll be stunt people in those cars. They'll all be strapped in. They'll have roll cages inside the cars, probably wearing crash helmets, some of them. So yeah, they'd be safe.
是的，有人的。车里会有特技演员。他们会系好安全带。车里会有防滚架，有些人可能还会戴着防撞头盔。所以，是的，他们很安全。
Almost all of Miles's questions were like this, about safety, some version of, are those people I'm seeing in the movie OK? Like in this one scene where the Blues brothers in their car go plowing through a mall, and all these people have to jump out of the way at the very last second.
迈尔斯几乎所有的问题都是这样的，关于安全，某种程度上就是：我在电影里看到的那些人还好吗？比如有个场景，布鲁斯兄弟开车冲进商场，所有人在最后一秒不得不跳开避让。
They're all stunt people that have been trained, and they all move on a cue, you know? They're really good because you can see they leave it right to the last second before they move. But that was lots of stunt people, lots of rehearsals.
那些都是受过训练的特技演员，他们都是按指令移动的，明白吗？他们非常专业，因为你可以看到，他们直到最后一秒才躲开。但那用了大量的特技演员和多次排练。
We continue. Miles shouts "pause" a couple more times, once to ask if Dan Aykroyd had to take special driving lessons-- answer, probably yes-- another time to ask if that car that goes flying through the air and sticks into the side of a truck is real-- answer, yes. And then we're at the climax of the chase, the one that Miles had drawn a picture of.
我们继续。迈尔斯又喊了几次“暂停”，一次是问丹·艾克罗伊德是否需要接受特殊的驾驶训练——回答是，很可能；另一次是问那辆飞向空中并插进卡车侧面的车是不是真的——回答是，真的。然后我们到了追逐的高潮，也就是迈尔斯画的那幅画。
The Blues Brothers are now being chased by just the Nazis, who are pursuing them ridiculously in the orange Ford Pinto. Blues Brothers gun it up an on-ramp to a highway. But oh, wait, the highway hasn't been built yet. It's just a ramp into the air. Blues Brothers hit reverse, somehow flip backward over the Nazi car behind them.
布鲁斯兄弟现在只被纳粹追捕，纳粹荒谬地开着那辆橙色福特平托紧追不舍。布鲁斯兄弟加速冲上高速公路匝道。但是，等等，公路还没建好。这只是一个通向空中的斜坡。布鲁斯兄弟倒车，以某种方式向后翻越了身后的纳粹车。
But the Nazi car keeps going, off the ramp and into the air. It flies through the air impossibly and comically far. And then there's a shot of it falling straight down a really long way. You see the Chicago skyline in the background, and the car smashes into the ground.
但纳粹的车继续向前，冲出了斜坡，飞向空中。它飞得不可思议且滑稽地远。然后是一个俯拍镜头，它真的很长一段距离地垂直下坠。背景里能看到芝加哥的天际线，最后车重重地砸在地上。
[CRASHING]
[撞击声]
Wait! Pause, pause, pause. This is where I had the question, how do they film that part?
等等！暂停，暂停，暂停。这就到了我的问题了，他们是怎么拍那一部分的？
Gary explains that they actually dropped the Ford Pinto from a helicopter.
加里解释说，他们实际上是从直升机上把福特平托扔下来的。
And then they're just dropping it. And then obviously, when the wide shot where you see the car dropping, again, that could be filmed from a helicopter or a building. And you're just seeing it dropping all the way down.
然后他们直接把它扔下去。显而易见，在那全景镜头中，你可以看到车在下坠，那是从直升机或高楼拍摄的。你只是看着它一直掉下去。
But like, the question I have for that part, are they OK once the car lands? Because you don't see it after it lands.
但我对那部分的问题是，车落地后他们还好吗？因为落地后你就看不到它了。
[CHUCKLES] So in the car, when it's dropping, when the physical car is dropping, they've probably got two dummies sitting in there, no real people.
[轻笑] 所以在车里，当实体车下坠时，里面大概放了两个假人，没有真人在里面。
Oh. But how did they get out?
哦。那他们是怎么出来的？
Gary explains that the interior shot of the two people in the car while it's falling, that was done separately, safely on the ground. Miles nods. Miles is actually the son of one of our coworkers here at the show, Alissa. She has a theory about Miles's interest in the Blues Brothers chase and all those questions about are the people safe, which is that some of it has to do with a thing that happened last summer. A girl Miles knows was in a pretty serious car accident. Miles told Gary about it.
加里解释说，车内两人坠落时的镜头是分开拍摄的，是在地面上安全完成的。迈尔斯点点头。迈尔斯其实是我们节目组同事阿丽莎的儿子。她有个关于迈尔斯为何对《福禄双霸天》的追逐戏感兴趣，以及为什么总问人们是否安全的原因，这和去年夏天发生的一件事有关。迈尔斯认识的一个女孩经历了一场相当严重的车祸。迈尔斯把这件事告诉了加里。
I have a friend. Her and her dad were driving in their old Subaru Outback. And they were at an intersection, and they stopped. There was a Kia Soul coming. There was a lady, a 95-year-old lady in the car, asleep at the wheel.
我有个朋友。她和她爸爸开着老式斯巴鲁傲虎。他们在十字路口停下。这时一辆起亚Soul冲过来。车里是一位95岁的老太太，在开车时睡着了。
Oh, dear.
哦，天哪。
And she rammed them into a tree.
她把他们撞向了一棵树。
Oh. Was they OK?
哦。他们没事吧？
Yeah, because my friend was strapped tightly into the back seat--
没事，因为我朋友被牢牢地系在后座上——
Oh.
哦。
--like, tightly.
——系得非常紧。
That's why you have to wear your seatbelts and all that. So that was lucky.
这就是为什么你必须系好安全带等等。所以那很幸运。
Hey, Gary, how often, when you're shooting a car chase, does somebody get hurt in the making of it?
嘿，加里，拍摄汽车追逐戏时，制作过程中有人受伤的情况多吗？
It's rare. I've, unfortunately, been involved in one car chase where someone got seriously hurt because the special effects rig failed. And that is obviously not a nice experience. But I think out of the 35 years that I've doing it, I've only had one serious accident in a car chase. Other than that, you might get a bit whiplash or something like that, but for us, that's nothing.
很少见。不幸的是，我参与过一次汽车追逐戏，有人因为特技装置故障而受了重伤。这显然不是什么愉快的经历。但在我从事这行的35年里，我只遇到过一次严重的事故。除此之外，你可能会受点轻微的鞭打伤之类的，但对我们来说，那不算什么。
Miles, can I ask you a question?
迈尔斯，我能问你个问题吗？
What?
什么？
Now that you know how this stuff is done, do you think it's better to know how they did the stunts or better not to know?
现在你知道这些是怎么拍出来的了，你觉得了解特技背后的真相更好，还是不了解更好？
Better. It's good to know how they do that, so you know that none of the people are just random people who have a chance of dying in the film or something. So that's the reason it's good to know.
更好。知道他们是怎么做的很好，这样你就知道电影里并没有什么随机的路人真的有生命危险之类的。这就是为什么知道这些很好。
It's nice when you get to talk to the exact right person. You get answers to the questions that have been circling in your head and, sometimes, reassurances you didn't even realize you were asking for.
当你能与最合适的人交谈时，感觉真好。你能得到一直萦绕在心头的问题的答案，有时甚至还能获得你都没意识到自己需要的慰藉。
Nice to meet you, Miles. Hope it makes things better for you.
很高兴见到你，迈尔斯。希望这能让你感觉好些。
Probably will.
应该会吧。
Well, today, we have stories of very idiosyncratic experts, all of them with super-specialized knowledge, giving life advice. We have one story about a comedian whose jokes have a strange power to change people's lives, another story about a woman in prison who uses the skills she learned outside prison to MacGyver solutions to all kinds of impossible problems, and another where the expert's expertise includes the fact that she successfully had an affair. In each of these, you really think, who else could have helped them? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
今天，我们会有一些非常有独特个性的专家故事，他们都拥有超专业的知识，并提供人生建议。其中一个故事关于一位喜剧演员，他的笑话有一种改变人们生活的奇怪力量；另一个故事关于一名女囚，她利用在监狱外学到的技能，设法解决了各种不可能的问题；还有一个专家，她的专业知识包括她曾成功有过一段婚外情。在这些故事里，你真的会想，还有谁能帮他们呢？这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, "Ask Daniel." This one starts with someone who gets some advice, though, interestingly, when it begins, they're not looking for advice. Aviva DeKornfeld has this one.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，“问丹尼尔”。不过有趣的是，这个故事开始时，当事人并没打算寻求建议。阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德带来的报道。
David was in a situation that so many people find themselves in at one point or another. He was in a relationship that, by every metric, was pretty good. And yet, somewhere, in the back of his mind, he found himself wondering if it was good enough. David was 24 and had been dating his girlfriend for three years at that point.
戴维正处于很多人在某个阶段都会经历的情况中。他的恋情从各项指标来看都很不错。然而，在他的潜意识深处，他还是会怀疑这是否已经“足够好”了。戴维当时24岁，和女友已经交往了三年。
I don't know if you've ever went through this yourself, where you just have this slight niggle, you know? And you go, I don't know what the niggle is because everything's perfect.
我不知道你是否经历过这种情况，就是心里总有一点点小疙瘩，你知道吗？然后你会想，我不知道这疙瘩是什么，因为一切都很完美。
And the niggle being like a little hint of doubt. Is that what that is?
那疙瘩就像是一点点怀疑，是吗？
Yeah, a slight doubt, slight confusion. It just didn't have that oomph. I'd say we were vanilla beige, but lovely.
对，一点点怀疑，一点点困惑。就是没有那种“怦然心动”的感觉。我会说我们平淡如水，但很可爱。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
So I mean, you wouldn't be thinking that we were maybe flying off to France and having a romantic getaway together. There was nothing wrong, but no-- no--
我是说，你不会觉得我们会飞去法国度假，来一场浪漫的旅行。一切都没错，但就是没有——没有——
Pasión?
激情？
Mm-hmm, yeah. Yeah, there was zero French in any of the relationship. It was a very British relationship.
嗯，对。对，这段关系里一点火花都没有。这是一种非常英式的关系。
One night, David's at a party without his girlfriend, talking with some people. And his friend Daniel, who's newly single and thrilled about it, starts telling everyone about his grand theory of love. He'd just come up with it.
一天晚上，戴维在没有女友的情况下参加聚会，和一些人聊天。他的朋友丹尼尔，刚恢复单身且对此兴奋不已，开始向大家讲述他伟大的爱情理论。这是他刚悟出来的。
The theory went like this-- our life is like a jigsaw puzzle. And as we grow up, we slowly piece the puzzle together, bit by bit. But the thing is, we've all lost the box to our individual jigsaws, so none of us know what image we're trying to make.
理论是这样的——我们的人生就像拼图。随着成长，我们一点一点地拼凑起来。但问题是，我们每个人都弄丢了自己那份拼图的盒子，所以没人知道我们最终要拼出的图像到底是什么。
So we start with the four sides-- our family, friends, job, hobbies. And then we're all taught that the piece at the very center of the jigsaw, the one we need to complete the puzzle, is our partner. And-- this is the important part-- people are so desperate to find their missing puzzle piece that, sometimes, they try to cram a piece that obviously doesn't fit or strip out other parts in order to make room for that center piece because they believe that to be better than being alone. David is listening to all of this.
所以我们从四个边开始——家庭、朋友、工作、爱好。然后我们被灌输，拼图中心的那块拼图，那块我们需要用来完成整个图像的，就是我们的伴侣。而——重点在于——人们为了找到那块缺失的拼图太绝望了，有时他们会硬塞进一块明显不合适的拼图，或者为了给中心拼图腾位置而拆掉其他部分，因为他们认为那样总好过孤独一人。戴维听着这一切。
I just had that "holy shit" moment of, this is my life you're describing right now, and I didn't realize it.
我当时就有一种“天哪”的感觉，这说的就是我的生活，但我之前没意识到。
David hadn't ever considered breaking up with his girlfriend because there was nothing to break up over. But hearing Daniel talk about this jigsaw analogy, David begins to panic.
戴维以前从没想过和女友分手，因为没啥可分手的理由。但听到丹尼尔的拼图类比，戴维开始恐慌。
And then I had this moment where I was like, what do I do? Like, what do I do now with this information? And he's like, well, I think you know what you need to do in this situation.
然后我那一刻心想，我该怎么办？我现在带着这些信息该怎么办？他说，嗯，我想你知道在这种情况下你需要做什么。
Oh, you literally asked him that? What do I do?
哦，你真的问他了？“我该怎么办？”
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I was really taken back.
哦，是的，真的。我当时被惊到了。
Daniel's analogy worms its way into David's brain. And once it's there, he can't shake it. So he breaks up with his girlfriend. And he actually explained the jigsaw analogy to her, as if anyone wants to hear that they're a misshapen puzzle piece, which he tells Daniel the next time he sees him.
丹尼尔的类比钻进了戴维的脑子里。一旦进去，他就无法摆脱。于是他还是和女友分手了。他还真向她解释了拼图理论，就好像有人愿意听自己是一块形状歪曲的拼图一样。他下一次见到丹尼尔时说了这件事。
How did it feel when he told you that they'd broken up because of what you'd said?
当他告诉你他们因为你说的话分手时，你感觉如何？
I mean, he was happy.
嗯，他是开心的。
Yeah?
是吗？
So it felt good. And I never thought that they were the perfect couple. I never thought that they would be together forever. Like, when they were together, I was like, oh, this ain't it. She's great. You're great. But you together ain't great.
所以感觉很好。我从不认为他们是完美的一对。我从没想过他们会永远在一起。他们在一起时我就觉得，哦，不是这块料。她很好，你很好，但你们凑在一起不好。
This is Daniel, David's friend. Another friend of theirs, who also heard Daniel's analogy, he broke up with his partner, too. Daniel had hit on something. He's a comedian, Daniel Sloss. Maybe you've heard of him. And feeling the wind of his friends' breakup under his sails, Daniel starts trying out this bit in bigger venues. He told it on stage at the Edinburgh Fringe Festival, performed it for a month straight.
这是戴维的朋友丹尼尔。他们的另一个朋友也听到了丹尼尔的类比，他也和伴侣分手了。丹尼尔确实说中了点什么。他是一名喜剧演员，丹尼尔·斯洛斯（Daniel Sloss）。也许你听说过他。在朋友分手这件事的鼓舞下，丹尼尔开始在更大的场合表演这个段子。他在爱丁堡艺穗节（Edinburgh Fringe Festival）舞台上讲了这个故事，连续表演了一个月。
Imagine all of our lives are like our own individual jigsaw puzzles. And as we're going through life, we're just slowly piecing it together, bit by bit.
想象一下，我们所有人的生活都像我们各自独立的拼图。随着生活推进，我们正一点一点地缓慢拼凑。
And one night, after the show--
然后有一天，演出结束后——
I was at a nightclub, and a girl came up to me. And she was like, I saw your show a week ago, and I broke up with my partner. And I was like, oh, cool. Awesome. Like, are you better for it? She was like, yeah, I'm way better for it. I'm much happier. That's why I'm out.
我在一家夜店，一个女孩走过来。她说，我一周前看了你的演出，我跟我伴侣分手了。我说，哦，酷。太棒了。那你感觉好点了吗？她说，是的，好多了。我快乐多了。所以我才出来玩。
Daniel felt like, oh, this little party trick works with strangers, too. He started touring with it, performing all around Scotland.
丹尼尔觉得，噢，这小把戏对陌生人也管用。他开始带着它巡演，在苏格兰各地表演。
Some of us will take the wrong person, the wrong jigsaw piece, and just fucking jam them into our jigsaws anyway.
我们有些人会拿错人，拿错拼图，然后还是硬生生地塞进自己的拼图里。
And after a show up in Dundee--
在邓迪（Dundee）的演出之后——
This-- he must have been about 50, 52 years old-- guy came up to me, and he went, hey man, just wanted to let you know I saw the show, and I finally got these through. And he showed me the first divorce papers. And I remember being like, oh, this is something.
那个人——他大概有50、52岁了——走过来对我说，嘿伙计，只是想让你知道我看了演出，我终于把这事儿办了。他给我看了离婚协议书。我记得当时心想，哦，这事儿不简单。
How long had they been married? Do you know?
他们结婚多久了？你知道吗？
[EXHALES] 20 years, I think?
[呼气] 我想有20年了吧？
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Yeah.
是的。
Then, there was the 19-year-old girl who brought her parents to the show in an attempt to make them realize they were miserable together. It worked. She asked him to autograph their divorce papers, which he did, happily. Then Daniel started taking the show abroad.
后来，还有个19岁的女孩带她父母来看演出，试图让他们意识到彼此在一起有多痛苦。奏效了。她让他给他们的离婚协议书签名，他愉快地签了。然后丹尼尔开始把演出带到海外。
We're in Hungary, and a guy had driven, I'm going to say, like, 800 miles from somewhere, like, in Russia with his divorce papers, just to see the show.
我们在匈牙利，有个人开车——我说是开车吧——大概800英里，从俄罗斯某个地方带着他的离婚协议书过来，就为了看这场演出。
So funny that people want to show you their divorce papers. It's like a cat bringing a dead bird to your doorstep.
人们想给你看他们的离婚协议书真是太搞笑了。就像猫把死鸟带到你家门口一样。
Yeah, that's it.
对，就是那样。
Like, I made it for you.
就像是，我把它当礼物献给你。
[LAUGHS] That's such a great way of describing it.
[大笑] 这种形容太棒了。
Daniel eventually turned this analogy into an hour-long special called Jigsaw. It's on Netflix. And the part in the special where he talks about love and couples stuck in bad relationships honestly feels more like a TED Talk than traditional standup.
丹尼尔最终把这个类比做成了一个小时的专场，叫《拼图》（Jigsaw）。在Netflix上有。专场里他谈论爱情和困在糟糕关系中的情侣的那部分，说实话，感觉更像是TED演讲而不是传统的单口喜剧。
You can spend five or more years with someone and only then, after all the fun you had, be looking at the jigsaw and realize you're both working towards very different images, only then realize that you want different things. And in that moment, you have a very, very difficult question to ask yourself. One, do I admit the last five years of my life have been a waste? Two, do I waste the rest of my life?
你可以和某人共度五年甚至更久，然后在那之后，在你们所有的快乐时光后，看着那张拼图，意识到你们都在朝着完全不同的图像努力，才意识到你们想要的东西不同。在那一刻，你有一个非常非常困难的问题要问自己。第一，我是否承认过去五年的生活是浪费？第二，我是否要浪费余生？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My generation has become so obsessed with starting the rest of their lives that they're willing to give up the one they are currently living. We have romanticized the idea of romance, and it is cancerous. I am very aware that this is not a particularly funny bit of the show.
我这一代人变得如此执着于开启剩余的人生，以至于他们愿意放弃现在正在过的人生。我们浪漫化了浪漫的概念，这是一种癌症。我非常清楚这段演出的笑点并不算多。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Toward the end of the special, Daniel says, if you break up with someone after watching this, please let me know. He's been keeping a rough tally of his breakup stats ever since. To date, between the people who come up to him in person, the tweets he's tagged in, the DMs he gets on Instagram, he estimates that as many as 30,000 couples have split up after seeing his show.
在专场快结束时，丹尼尔说，如果有人看了这表演后分手了，请告诉他。从那以后，他一直在粗略统计自己的分手案例。到目前为止，在亲口告诉他的人、提到他的推文、Instagram上的私信中，他估计有多达3万对情侣在看了他的演出后分手了。
The thing I don't understand is, the stuff Daniel says in his special, most of it is not particularly novel. His jigsaw analogy isn't that far from a lot of the stuff you might find in a self-help book. Like, the idea that you should be happy and whole on your own and you shouldn't settle, that's the thing people tell you about love. So what is it about this guy and the way that he delivers this familiar message? Why is it so effective?
我不明白的是，丹尼尔在专场里说的东西，大部分并没有什么特别新颖的地方。他的拼图类比和你在自助书中能找到的内容相差不大。比如，你应该在独处时感到快乐和完整，不应该凑合，这些本来就是人们在爱情中告诉你的事。那么，这个人以及他传达这个熟悉信息的方式到底有什么特别之处？为什么它如此有效？
I wanted to talk to some of the people who broke up after watching Jigsaw, and let me tell you, they were not very hard to find. I heard from over 50 people from all over-- the US, the UK, Australia, Italy, Kazakhstan, the United Arab Emirates. I spoke with eight of them.
我想和一些在看了《拼图》后分手的人谈谈，我得说，找到他们并不难。我收到了来自全球各地超过50个人的反馈——美国、英国、澳大利亚、意大利、哈萨克斯坦、阿联酋。我采访了其中八个人。
And there is a real fervor to Daniel's fandom. People speak about him breathlessly, with a kind of awe. They'll quote lines from his special like it's Scripture or something. One person said she and her friends say, "In Sloss We Trust," as their motto. And there are a lot of people out there walking around with puzzle piece tattoos.
丹尼尔的粉丝有一种真正的狂热。人们带着一种敬畏，喘着气谈论他。他们会引用专场里的台词，就像引用圣经一样。有个人说她和朋友把“信斯洛斯得永生”（In Sloss We Trust）当座右铭。还有很多人身上纹着拼图纹身。
Most of the people I spoke with have watched the special over and over to fully absorb the teachings. Some return to it in moments of doubt after breaking up with their partner. And what's crazy to me is that no one I talked to had had any immediate plans to break up with their partner when they first sat down to watch it.
我采访的大多数人都把专场反复看了又看，以充分吸收其中的教诲。有些人会在分手后的动摇时刻重温它。令我疯狂的是，我采访的每个人在坐下来看之前，都没有任何立即与伴侣分手的计划。
I came away from those conversations with a couple of theories as to why Daniel's message hit so hard. And I want to tell you about one person in particular, Charlotte, because her story encompasses all of them. Charlotte watched Jigsaw back in 2018, shortly after it came out. She's from East London and, like everyone I spoke with, got together with her husband when she was super young. She was 20, still figuring out who she was.
我从那些谈话中得到了几个关于为什么丹尼尔的信息如此震撼的理论。我想讲其中一个人，夏洛特（Charlotte），因为她的故事涵盖了所有这些点。夏洛特在2018年，也就是《拼图》刚出不久后就看了。她来自东伦敦，和所有我采访的人一样，她在很年轻的时候就和丈夫在一起了。她那时20岁，还在摸索自己是谁。
And Charlotte, like the others, just kind of thought, I guess this is what it feels like to be in a long-term relationship. It was flat, just flat. Charlotte had been with her husband for six years when she sat down one night to watch a special alone.
和别人一样，夏洛特只是想，我想这就是长期关系的感觉吧。它太平淡了，就是平淡。夏洛特和丈夫在一起六年了，那天晚上她独自坐下来看专场。
I can remember sitting there and actually not touching my phone, not scroll on anything. I was absolutely hooked on what he was saying because it felt like he was talking to me, in a weird way. There's a part in the show where he said, you think that you're so special, you think you found your soulmate 30 minutes down the road? And I was like, oh, no.
我记得当时坐在那儿，真的一下都没碰手机，也没刷别的东西。我被他说的话完全吸引住了，因为那种感觉就像他在对我说话，很奇妙。秀里有部分他说，你以为你很特别，你以为你在离家20英里远的地方找到了灵魂伴侣？我当时想，哦，不。
There are 7.5 billion people on this planet. And you found your soulmate 20 miles from where you live?
地球上有75亿人。而你在离家20英里远的地方找到了灵魂伴侣？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It was one of those things that it just dawned on me that I've settled. It's like settling into a bad job. You're still getting paid. You're still going through the motions. There's somebody there. You go on holiday. It's not like you're overly happy, but you're not overly sad.
就是那种我突然意识到我凑合了的感觉。就像从事一份糟糕的工作。你还在拿工资，你还在走过场。有人在那里，你们去度假，不是说你不快乐，但也绝不算快乐。
Right after watching the special, Charlotte tells her husband, you need to see this-- which, interestingly, was another thing so many of the people I spoke with did. Charlotte told me she hoped it would prompt her husband to take a hard look at their relationship, like it had for her. No such luck. He spent the whole hour on his phone scrolling, not listening at all.
看完专场后，夏洛特立刻告诉丈夫，你需要看这个——有趣的是，这也是我采访的许多人做过的事。夏洛特告诉我，她希望这能促使她丈夫像她一样认真审视他们的关系。但没那么幸运。他整个小时都在手机上刷屏，根本没听。
Even after I started following the breakup tally on Twitter, he still wasn't kind of getting how much it really had resonated with me.
即使在我开始在推特上关注分手计数后，他还是没能意识到这对我产生了多大的共鸣。
Wait, you showed him how many people had broken up as a result of this special, as like a nudge?
等等，你让他看了有多少人因为这个专场分手，作为一种暗示？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的，是的。
Oh, my god. And what did he say?
哦，我的天。他说什么？
Oh, OK.
噢，好吧。
It sounds like you were kind of trying to tee him up to break up with you. Is that right?
听起来你当时是在暗示他跟你分手。对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
But he was not paying attention?
但他没注意？
No.
没有。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
He was not.
他没注意。
In the end, she had to do it. So how did Daniel manage to break through to Charlotte? She says part of it was that she was just caught completely off-guard. She had no idea what she was getting into when she decided to watch Jigsaw. Everyone I spoke with said something like this, that the fact that the advice came in the form of a comedy special made it easier to hear, like wrapping a pill in cheese for an unsuspecting dog.
最终，她不得不自己提出来。那么丹尼尔是如何成功触动夏洛特的？她说部分原因在于她完全没有防备。当她决定看《拼图》时，根本不知道自己会面对什么。我采访的每一个人都说了类似的话，即这种建议以喜剧形式包装，让它更容易被接受，就像给毫无戒心的狗喂药时在药丸外裹上芝士。
I didn't go into watching Jigsaw thinking that I was going to be thinking about breaking up my marriage. I was there for a laugh.
我坐下来看《拼图》时，没想过我会考虑结束我的婚姻。我只是想找点乐子。
Another thing about Daniel-- he's super prescriptive. Charlotte wasn't happy, but that low hum of dissatisfaction she felt, it never quite seemed like enough to blow her life up over. But in his special, it's like Daniel reached out of the screen and grabbed Charlotte by the shoulders and told her, actually, that is enough.
关于丹尼尔的另一件事——他非常独断。夏洛特当时并不快乐，但她感受到的那种淡淡的不满，似乎永远不足以让她炸毁自己的生活。但在他的专场里，就像丹尼尔从屏幕里伸出手，抓着夏洛特的肩膀告诉她，其实，那已经足够了。
It felt like he was saying, well, Charlotte, [CHUCKLES] just because you don't love him anymore doesn't mean you can't break up with him. It's like, you can break up with him. Breaking up with someone because you've grown as a person is a valid reason. You should break up with someone whenever.
感觉他就像在说，嗯，夏洛特，[轻笑] 仅仅因为你不爱他了，并不意味着你不能和他分手。就像是，你可以和他分手。因为个人成长而和某人分手是一个正当理由。你应该随时可以和某人分手。
And you had never had a friend or a family member say it that directly to you?
以前从来没有朋友或家人这么直接地对你说过吗？
No.
没有。
Not at all. Charlotte's younger sister hated how different Charlotte was whenever her husband was around, but her sister never told her outright to break up. Her mom understood that she was unhappy and making a lot of sacrifices in her marriage, but would also say things like, I'm not going to tell you what to do. Whenever Charlotte's family and friends observed that she didn't seem particularly happy with her husband--
根本没有。夏洛特的妹妹讨厌夏洛特在丈夫身边时那种完全变了的样子，但她妹妹从来没直接告诉她分手。她妈妈理解她不快乐，在婚姻中做出了很多牺牲，但也会说类似“我不会告诉你该怎么做”的话。每当夏洛特的家人和朋友发现她似乎对丈夫并不快乐时——
I would defend him. I would say, oh, well, he's tired, you know? He works nights, and would always defend his behavior, even though he would embarrass me. And, ugh, the fact that I could tell that my family didn't like him and they didn't think that he was-- [SIGHS] he wasn't right for me hurt more because I'd made that choice.
我会维护他。我会说，噢，好吧，他太累了，你知道吗？他上夜班，我总是维护他的行为，尽管他让我感到尴尬。还有，呃，我能感觉到家人不喜欢他，觉得他不是——[叹气] 他不适合我，这让我更难受，因为那是我做的选择。
Do you think it was easier to hear the message from Daniel because he was a stranger?
你觉得从一个陌生人那里听到这些信息更容易吗？
Yeah. People take advice from strangers sometimes more than they do the people closest to them because they don't care in the sense that if I see someone on the tube or whatever, and they've got lipstick on their teeth, and I literally-- I make eye contact with them, and I do that, that motion of, like, wipe their teeth, your friend is going to worry about how to say that to you. I don't care. Like, you've got lipstick on your teeth. [CHUCKLES] You've got egg on your face.
是的。人们有时比接受身边最亲近的人的建议更容易接受陌生人的建议，因为他们不在乎，就像如果在地铁上看到某人，他们牙齿上沾了口红，我直接——我和他们对视，做出擦牙齿的动作，你的朋友会担心该怎么跟你说，我才不在乎。你牙齿上有口红。[轻笑] 你脸上沾了蛋黄。
Daniel's a stranger. This, I think, is another reason why he's able to cut through. Because there's no embarrassment when you hear what he thinks about your bad choices, the way you might feel with a friend. Daniel is a neutral party who can point out a problem on his way out the door entirely uninvested in what happens next.
丹尼尔是个陌生人。我认为这是他能突破防线的原因之一。因为当你听到他认为你的糟糕选择时，没有那种面对朋友时可能产生的尴尬。丹尼尔是一个中立的第三方，他在离开时指出问题，完全不关心后续会发生什么。
I think there's one more reason so many people split up after watching Jigsaw, maybe the most important factor in all this. I first heard about Jigsaw when it came out in 2018. At the time, I was in a relationship with someone who was pretty clearly not a good match for me long-term. And so when I heard how many couples this special was breaking up, I thought, no way am I watching that. I know it'll happen. My relationship will never survive this.
我想为什么有那么多人看了《拼图》后分手，还有最后一个原因，可能是所有因素中最重要的一点。我第一次听说《拼图》是在2018年它刚出来时。当时，我正处于一段显然不适合我长期的关系中。所以当我听说这个专场让多少情侣分手时，我想，我绝不会看。我知道会发生什么。我的关系绝对经不起这个。
I'm not in that situation anymore. So recently, I decided it was finally safe to see the show. And I have to say, I was totally right to be scared of it. There are moments in there that I know would have gotten me back then, like this terrible thought about being in a relationship that you don't know how to leave--
我现在已经不在那种处境了。所以最近，我决定终于可以安全地看这场秀了。我得说，我害怕它完全是对的。里面有几刻我知道如果当时看一定会戳中我，比如这种关于处在一段不知道如何离开的关系中的可怕想法——
But you just sit there, and you wait. You wait looking for an excuse to get out, just waiting for them to do something unforgivable so that you can actually break up with them with a real excuse and leave with your head held high. But because unlike you, they're not a piece of shit, they won't do that.
你只是坐在那儿，等待。你等待着寻找一个离开的借口，只是等待他们做出什么不可饶恕的事情，这样你就可以真的以一个真正的理由分手，并且可以昂着头离开。但因为不像你，他们不是人渣，他们不会那样做。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So you have to start lowering your standards for what unforgivable is.
所以你不得不开始降低对于什么是“不可饶恕”的标准。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
One week in, you're like, if they cheat on me, this is perfect. I can leave with my head held high, and I will not look like a dick. Nine weeks later, they're faithful, and you're like, man, if they buy orange juice with pulp in it, that is--
一周后，你会想，如果他们出轨，那就完美了。我可以昂首离开，而且我看起来不会像个混蛋。九周后，他们很忠诚，你会想，天哪，如果他们买含果肉的橙汁，那就是——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I can't live like that. All I'm asking is, if you've ever been in a situation like that, in a relationship where you felt trapped, like you couldn't get out of it, and it was just easier to stay in it, all I'm asking is, even for the briefest of seconds, have you ever accidentally caught yourself thinking how much easier life would be--
我没法那样生活。我唯一想问的是，如果你曾经处于这种情况中，在一段你感到被困住、觉得无法脱身的关系中，觉得留下来更容易，我唯一想问的是，即使只有极其短暂的几秒钟，你是否曾无意中发现自己在想，如果他们直接死了，生活会轻松多少——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--if they were to just die?
——如果他们就这样死了？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And not because you want them to die, but just because them dying is the easiest way for you to get out of that relationship. And it doesn't involve either one of you getting hurt--
不是因为你想要他们死，而是因为他们的死亡是你摆脱那段关系的最简单方式。而且这不需要你们任何一方在情感上——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--emotionally.
——受到伤害。
I have to say, I totally had that thought in my 2018 relationship. And it's not even that you want the other person to die so much as you just kind of want them to evaporate because breaking up with them just feels impossible. I had never said this thought out loud before watching the special. I didn't even know this was a thought other people had.
我不得不说，我在2018年的那段关系中完全有过这种想法。你甚至不是那么想要对方死，更多只是想要他们消失，因为分手的感觉简直是不可能的。在看这个专场之前，我从来没大声说出过这个想法。我甚至不知道其他人也有这种想法。
And hearing it laid out in such a bare way, I know it would have been impossible to ignore. That's the thing about the show. The jigsaw analogy is a sound that only people in quietly unhappy relationships can hear. If what Daniel is saying reaches you, it's because there's a little radio tower in your head tuned to receive his message.
当它如此赤裸地呈现出来时，我知道忽略它是不可能的。这就是这场秀的魅力。拼图类比是一种只有处于安静而不快乐的关系中的人才能听到的声音。如果丹尼尔说的内容触动了你，那是因为你脑子里有一个小小的无线电塔，正调频接收他的信息。
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer on our show. Daniel Sloss's specials, including the one you just heard about, are at danielsloss.com/streaming. Watch it if you dare. Coming up, let's do this one Jeopardy-style. The answer is combine "no more tears" baby shampoo and Vaseline into a paste. The question? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制片人。丹尼尔·斯洛斯的专场，包括你刚听到的那个，都在danielsloss.com/streaming。如果你敢，就看吧。接下来，我们要用《危险边缘》（Jeopardy）的方式来做这个。答案是：将“无泪”婴儿洗发水和凡士林混合成糊状。问题是什么？一分钟后，芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm David Kestenbaum in for Ira Glass. Our show today, You've Come to the Right Person, stories about people finding very specific guides through life's great mysteries. We've arrived at Act Two, "Ask Kwaneta."
这里是《美国生活》。我是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆，代班艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“你找对人了”，关于人们在人生重大迷局中寻找特定向导的故事。我们进入第二幕，“问关妮塔”（Ask Kwaneta）。
So this story is about someone with very specialized knowledge, giving advice in a very specific place. I'll just note, if you're listening with kids, this story includes some adult topics. It's an essay by Kwaneta Harris. And to introduce it, one of our co-workers here, Diane Wu, called her up.
这个故事关于一个拥有非常专业知识的人，在特定的地方提供建议。我顺便提醒一下，如果你和孩子一起听，这个故事包含一些成人话题。这是关妮塔·哈里斯（Kwaneta Harris）写的文章。为了引出它，我们节目组的同事黛安·吴（Diane Wu）打了个电话给她。
So, Kwaneta, can you say where you are right now?
关妮塔，你能说说你现在在哪里吗？
I am in my cell in Texas in a women's prison.
我在德克萨斯州女子监狱的牢房里。
And before you were incarcerated, what was your job? What was your special expertise?
在你入狱前，你的工作是什么？你有什么特别的专长？
Oh, I was a nurse. I was a nurse who floated from the emergency room to oncology to geriatric care, home health care. Can you hear me OK here? Or should I stand somewhere else? Am I OK?
噢，我是一名护士。我是一名在急诊室、肿瘤科、老年护理、家庭护理之间流动的护士。你听得清我说话吗？还是我应该站到别的地方去？我可以吗？
Yeah. Where is that? Where are you standing?
可以。你在哪里？你站在哪里？
On top of the toilet seat.
站在马桶盖上。
Really? [CHUCKLES]
真的吗？[轻笑]
Holding my tablet in the air like Lady Liberty.
像自由女神像一样，把平板电脑举在空中。
Like the Statue of Liberty? [CHUCKLES]
像自由女神像？[轻笑]
Yeah. And I have the other hand on the wall to hold on.
是啊。另一只手扶着墙保持平衡。
So you and I have been working on this story for a while now, right?
你和我一直在做这个故事有一阵子了，对吧？
Yes. It's been a minute.
是的，有一会儿了。
Yeah. And we were hoping to come to the prison and record you, but they denied our request. And since the phone line is bad, and we don't want you to have to read the story standing on top of your toilet, we decided to bring in an actor to read the essay instead.
是啊。我们曾希望能去监狱采访录音，但他们拒绝了我们的申请。既然电话线路很差，我们也不想让你站着马桶读这个故事，所以我们决定请一位演员来朗读这篇文章。
Oh, thank god.
哦，谢天谢地。
Could you read the first couple of lines of the story to get us started? And then we'll cross-fade to the actor.
你能读一下故事的前几行让我们开始吗？然后我们会过渡到那位演员。
Sure.
好的。
The first thing that happened was I lost everything. I remember exactly the moment I realized it.
发生的第一件事是我失去了一切。我清楚地记得我意识到这一刻的时候。
I remember exactly the moment I realized it.
我清楚地记得我意识到这一刻的时候。
It was in 2009--
那是在2009年——
It was in 2009, just a couple of weeks after I had been transferred from the county jail to prison. I'd injured my shoulder working in the kitchen, stirring pots with canoe-sized paddles.
那是在2009年，就在我从县监狱转移到监狱几周后。我在厨房工作时弄伤了肩膀，用那种独木舟大小的桨搅拌锅。
So I went to medical. I entered a crowded waiting room, interrupting a lecture by a med tech and a guard, when they asked me, what did I want? With all eyes on me, I said, I need some ibuprofen for my shoulder. The med tech launched into a sermon-- stop looking for a quick fix; stop popping pills; try to stay clean; pray on it; drink more water and lose weight. All that for a few Motrin.
所以我去了医务室。我走进拥挤的候诊室，打断了一个医技人员和一名狱警的谈话。当他们问我要什么时，在众目睽睽之下，我说：“我的肩膀需要一些布洛芬。”那位医技人员开始长篇大论——别老想着找捷径；别乱吃药；试着保持清醒；多祈祷；多喝水，多减肥。就为了几片止痛药，全是这些废话。
As she talked, I noticed she was wearing the exact same scrubs I had in my bedroom closet at home-- light blue ones with the pink breast cancer awareness ribbon all over them. It hit me like a body punch to see her in those scrubs, talking to me in such dehumanizing language. Before, she would have been one of my colleagues. Now, I was on this other side, and there was no way back.
在她说话时，我注意到她穿的洗手服和我家里衣橱里的一模一样——浅蓝色，上面印满了粉红色的乳腺癌宣传丝带。看到她穿着那件衣服，用那种非人化的语言跟我说话，这简直是对我身体的一记重击。以前，她本该是我的同事。现在，我站在了另一边，再也回不去了。
But then, a window back to my old life appeared. I started to get medical questions from the women incarcerated with me. It took a few years. Word got out early on that I was a nurse. But there are many nurses in prison. Some of them are in prison because they were doing nefarious things as a nurse, so people didn't want to ask them for help.
但后来，通往我旧生活的一扇窗户出现了。我开始收到和我一起被监禁的女性发来的医疗问题。花了几年的时间。消息很早就传开了，我知道我是个护士。但监狱里有很多护士。有些人入狱是因为她们作为护士做了邪恶的事情，所以人们不想向她们寻求帮助。
But once it was cleared up that I wasn't one of the nurses that hurt their patients, I slowly started getting questions. People would come and talk to me in the yard or in the shower. Or when people were too ashamed to ask out loud, they would write it down on a tiny slip of paper and get it to me. First, it was just the girls in my dorm. Then they started asking for their friends, who told their friends.
但一旦澄清我不是那种伤害病人的护士，我就慢慢开始接到问题。人们会在操场或淋浴间找我交谈。或者当人们羞于大声询问时，她们会把问题写在小纸条上给我。起初，只是我宿舍里的姑娘们。后来她们开始替朋友问，朋友的朋友也来问。
Now, over a decade later, I get notes from almost every women's prison in Texas. These notes are surreptitiously passed during meal time or laundry exchange, tucked into dirty socks or folded under a tray, passed between women from different prisons on the bus to the prison hospital. Many are from strangers who have just heard that they can write to Mama Detroit-- that's me.
现在，十多年过去了，我收到来自德克萨斯州几乎每一所女子监狱的纸条。这些纸条在吃饭或换洗衣物时偷偷传递，塞进脏袜子里或折叠在托盘下，在去监狱医院的巴士上在不同监狱的女性之间传递。许多来自刚听说可以写信给“底特律妈妈”（Mama Detroit）的陌生人——那就是我。
They're folded up in a square with tiny writing on white or colored pieces of paper, on the inside of candy wrappers, the thin plastic from Kotex pads. I even get questions on squares of toilet paper. One reads, "My roommate uses her inhaler all the time. I think she's addicted to it. Is that possible?"
纸条被折成正方形，上面写着微小的字，纸张有白色或彩色的，有糖果包装纸内侧的，有Kotex卫生巾的薄塑料皮。我甚至收到过卫生纸块上的问题。其中一个写着：“我的室友总是用她的吸入器。我觉得她对它上瘾了。这可能吗？”
Another girl who's in a church choir here wrote about someone she sings with. "When she sings, her breath smells up the whole choir. Her teeth are all rotten, and peppermints are not helping. What can we do?" The range of questions people ask is very wide, anything from, "What's this medicine for?" to, "Which homemade dildo is safest?" None of them.
另一个在这里唱诗班的女孩写了关于一个一起唱歌的人的事。“她唱歌时，呼吸味儿弥漫整个唱诗班。她的牙齿都烂了，薄荷糖也没用。我们该怎么办？”人们询问问题的范围非常广泛，从“这个药是治什么的？”到“哪种自制假阳具最安全？”等等，应有尽有。
Everyone involved in passing the notes is taking a risk-- the writer, the person delivering the note, me. If you're caught with a note on you, it can be a disciplinary infraction, possession of contraband. If you have three or more of these infractions in 30 days, that can get upgraded to a major case, which can be used to justify a parole denial. I deliberately store all my unread notes in a brown paper bag in the corner of my cell, so I can always claim it's trash.
参与传递纸条的每个人都在冒险——写字的人、送纸条的人、还有我。如果你被抓到持有纸条，这可能构成纪律处分，属于持有违禁品。如果在30天内有三次或更多此类违规，那可能升级为重大案件，这会被用来作为拒绝假释的理由。我故意把所有没读过的纸条存在牢房角落的一个棕色纸袋里，这样我总能谎称那是垃圾。
Lou wrote to me about her friend Prissy, who bought contraband eyeshadow from someone working in the prison print shop. The print shop has pretty bright-powdered ink that people steal for makeup. Lou wrote that Prissy couldn't get the blue eyeshadow off. "She tried toothpaste. It stained. She looking like a fat-ass Smurf."
卢（Lou）写信给我关于她的朋友普里西（Prissy），普里西从监狱印刷厂工作的人那儿买了违禁眼影。印刷厂有相当明亮的粉末状油墨，人们会偷来当化妆品。卢写道，普里西弄不掉那蓝色的眼影。“她试了牙膏。它染色了。她看起来像个胖蓝精灵。”
I wrote back, "Mix No More Tears Baby Shampoo and Vaseline into a paste. Apply to your eyelid overnight, then wipe rubbing alcohol repeatedly to the area. It will slowly fade to green and then eventually disappear." I know this won't be the last time someone accidentally cosplays a cartoon character, though. We all miss feeling human, you know? Like our old selves.
我回信说：“混合‘无泪’婴儿洗发水和凡士林成糊状。晚上涂在眼睑上，然后用酒精反复擦拭该区域。它会慢慢褪色成绿色，最终消失。”我知道这不会是最后一次有人意外地模仿卡通人物，对吧？我们都怀念那种做人的感觉，你知道吗？就像我们以前的自己一样。
For me, answering these questions, it made me feel like my old self. It was a way for me to still be a caregiver. I felt needed. I was needed in a very particular way I hadn't been on the outside. Because first, the medical care that exists in our prison is extremely lacking. There are only a handful of medical providers for the 1,200 people here. You have to pay to go to medical, $13.55 per visit, which is a king's ransom when we're forced to work in here for free. And when you get there, they treat you like crap.
对我来说，回答这些问题让我觉得自己还是原来的自己。这是我继续成为看护者的一种方式。我觉得被需要。我以一种我在外面时没有过的方式被需要着。因为首先，我们监狱里的医疗保健极其匮乏。这里有1200人，只有少数几个医疗提供者。你看病要花钱，每次13.55美元，当我们被迫在这里无偿工作时，这简直是天价。当你真的去了那里，他们对待你就像对待垃圾。
And the medical staff can't answer their questions as well as I can because unlike the people they're treating, they aren't incarcerated. I know the materials available to women-- Vaseline, baby shampoo. I know the exact way to ask for certain treatments without getting punished.
而且医护人员回答问题的水平不如我，因为不像他们治疗的人，他们没有被监禁。我知道女性可以获得的材料——凡士林、婴儿洗发水。我知道如何在不被惩罚的情况下要求进行特定治疗的准确方法。
Like for yeast infections, going in and saying "I have a yeast infection" will often lead the nurse to start asking about your sex life. And if you let slip that you have a girlfriend, the guards supervising your appointment can write you a disciplinary. The safer way I tell people is to tell the nurse you took antibiotics recently and are noticing this side effect. You have to let the nurse think she figured it out.
比如霉菌感染，进去直接说“我有霉菌感染”往往会导致护士开始询问你的性生活。如果你一不小心说漏嘴你有女朋友，监管你预约的狱警可以给你记一次纪律违规。我告诉人们更安全的方法是告诉护士你最近服用了抗生素，并注意到这个副作用。你得让护士以为是她自己发现的。
Also, I know the various factors the women are weighing when they consider their own care. For instance, early on, one of the most common medical questions people would write to me was, "Do I really need to get a mammogram?"
此外，我也了解女性在考虑自己的护理时所权衡的各种因素。例如，早期最常见的医疗问题之一是，“我真的需要去做乳房X光检查吗？”
I know what they mean when they ask this. We all hate the mammogram trip. We have to take a nausea inducing bus ride that freezes us during the winter and cooks us in the summers. We have to pack all of our belongings to send to storage while we're gone. And when we move back, they assign us a new roommate. It's so hard to get a decent roommate. Few people want to risk losing that by leaving.
我知道她们问这个是什么意思。我们都讨厌乳房检查之旅。我们得坐那种令人作呕的巴士，冬天冻得要死，夏天热得要命。我们必须在离开期间打包所有行李送到储藏室。当我们回来时，他们会给我们分配新的室友。找个好室友太难了。很少有人愿意冒着失去好室友的风险离开。
When people ask me if it's worth going on the trip, I write back, explaining breast cancer and ask if their mom or anyone else in their family has a history of cancer. I try to convince them and myself that it's only once a year and probably worth going.
当人们问我是否值得去这一趟时，我回信解释乳腺癌，并询问她们的妈妈或家人是否有癌症病史。我试着劝她们，也劝我自己，这每年只有一次，很可能值得去。
But the prison instituted a new rule last summer. They now promise to hold our assigned bed and roommate for a week. People are still refusing to go, though, even though you could get a disciplinary infraction if you skipped the trip. Ain't nobody riding in that wheeled cauldron.
但监狱去年夏天实施了一项新规定。他们现在承诺保留我们分配的床位和室友一周。然而，人们仍然拒绝去，即使不参加会有被纪律处分的风险。没人想坐那个轮子上的锅炉。
More questions I've received-- "My roommate got lupus. Can I catch it from her?" No, you don't have to worry about that. It's an autoimmune disease, which means it's her body fighting her body. This girl wrote me and said, "I pee only a little bit each time I go. Is this my prostate?" That's not your prostate. You don't have one. This is a UTI.
我收到的更多问题——“我的室友得了红斑狼疮。我会传染吗？”不，你不必担心这个。这是一种自身免疫性疾病，意思是她的身体在攻击她自己的身体。有个女孩写信给我说，“我每次小便只有一点点。这是我的前列腺吗？”那不是你的前列腺。你没有前列腺。这是尿路感染。
I have two girls in here who wrote me with signs and symptoms of endometriosis. The problem is, the only way you can diagnose endometriosis is surgery. I'm still figuring out what to write back to them.
我这里有两个女孩写信给我，有子宫内膜异位症的迹象和症状。问题是，诊断子宫内膜异位症的唯一方法是手术。我还在想该怎么回复她们。
I used to think my special expertise was to help women who were incarcerated with me. But then, I started getting mail from released friends, too, like one from my friend I'll call Flaca, who asked me what can she drink to get rid of her pregnancy? She was sexually assaulted by a guest at the motel where she works.
我曾经以为我的特殊专长是帮助与我一同被监禁的女性。但后来，我开始收到释放的朋友的来信，比如一个我称为“弗拉卡”（Flaca）的朋友，她问我喝什么能打掉孩子。她在工作的汽车旅馆被一个客人强奸了。
Abortions are illegal in Texas. Flaca has a snitch on her ankle in the form of an electronic GPS monitor, so she can't slip over to New Mexico and get abortion care. She can't get medical abortion pills mailed to her in the faith-based halfway house that opens all incoming mail. Flaca still has to figure out how to get health care while being surveilled and restricted. These days, it feels like women all over Texas do, not just those of us in prison.
德克萨斯州堕胎是非法的。弗拉卡脚踝上有个电子GPS监控器，所以她不能溜去新墨西哥州接受堕胎护理。她不能让堕胎药寄到会拆开所有进站邮件的信教半途之家。弗拉卡仍然必须在受到监控和限制的情况下弄清楚如何获得医疗保健。如今，感觉德克萨斯州各地的女性都如此，不仅仅是我们这些在监狱里的。
All I could tell her was to call the National Planned Parenthood hotline, not from her phone, because parole officers might search her phone history. I was relieved to hear that she ended up getting the pills by having them delivered to someone else's address. I just hope it's a friend, somebody who won't try to extort or tell on her. Flaca is still on parole. Since receiving Flaca's letter a year ago, I have received eight more letters from women asking for abortion care resources.
我能告诉她的只是拨打全国计划生育联合会（Planned Parenthood）的热线，不能用她的手机，因为假释官可能会搜查她的手机记录。听到她最终通过把药寄到别人的地址得到了药，我松了口气。我只希望那是朋友，一个不会试图勒索或告发她的人。弗拉卡还在假释期。自一年前收到弗拉卡的信以来，我又收到了八封女性询问堕胎护理资源的信。
When I've needed medical advice, I don't have anyone to ask for help. I've had to figure out how to be my own Mama Detroit. About nine years ago, I was sent to solitary confinement, and a few years in, I started to feel like I was losing it. I couldn't sleep, and I started to get incredibly emotional.
当我需要医疗建议时，我没处求助。我不得不学会如何做我自己的“底特律妈妈”。大约九年前，我被关进禁闭室，过了几年，我开始觉得我快疯了。我无法入睡，开始变得极其情绪化。
One day, one of the girls below me told three of us through a shared heating vent-- that's our phone-- about a letter from her father asking for forgiveness. As I stood listening at my vent, I just couldn't stop crying. This was not normal for me, but I had read about how, in solitary, people react differently to extreme isolation.
有一天，下面有个女孩通过通风口——那是我们的电话——告诉我们三个人她父亲要求宽恕的一封信。当我站在通风口听着时，我无法停止哭泣。这对我不正常，但我读过关于在禁闭中，人们对极度隔绝的反应不同的文章。
Then my memory started to go. I started needing to use my cell walls as a whiteboard to jot down reminders for myself-- the date of my daughter's next volleyball game or what three things I wanted to talk about at my next doctor appointment. My memory has always been really, really good. My second husband used to say that we got divorced because of my memory because I just couldn't let things go. It was hard to let go that he kept cheating.
然后我的记忆力开始衰退。我开始需要用牢房的墙壁作为白板来记提醒——女儿下场排球比赛的日期，或者我想在下一次医生预约时谈论的三件事。我的记忆力一直都非常好。我的第二任丈夫曾说，我们离婚是因为我的记忆力，因为我就是无法放下事情。他一直在出轨，这很难放下。
So when I started not being able to remember anything, it was a really scary moment for me. I couldn't focus on what I was reading. My body ached. It was late 2020, and I thought, this is long COVID. This is solitary confinement.
所以当我开始什么都记不住时，那是一个非常可怕的时刻。我无法专注于我读的东西。我的身体很疼。那是2020年末，我想，这就是新冠后遗症。这就是禁闭。
Finally, one of my friends on the outside wrote to me saying, you think it might be menopause? I told her, I am not that old. I was only 48. They never taught us about menopause in nursing school. It was just some punchline about hot flashes, which I started to get, too.
最终，我在外面的一个朋友写信给我说，你觉得可能是更年期吗？我告诉她，我没那么老。我才48岁。护理学校从没教过我们更年期。那只是关于潮热的一个笑话，我也开始出现了。
There isn't air conditioning in our prison building in Texas. It gets so hot in the summer that Coke cans will just spontaneously explode. Toothpaste liquefies. In June 2019, I fainted from the heat, and the sergeant took the temperature in my cell that day-- 129 degrees. So I already felt like I was being cooked before the hot flashes.
我们在德克萨斯州的监狱大楼里没有空调。夏天热得可乐罐都会直接炸开。牙膏会液化。2019年6月，我因高温昏倒了，中士那天测量了我牢房的温度——129华氏度（约54摄氏度）。所以，在潮热出现之前，我就已经觉得自己在被烧烤了。
But when that burning feeling hits the middle of my chest, then radiates to the rest of my body, it's unbearable. I learned to keep bowls filled with tap water to dump over my head at the start of each hot flash. I always expect the water to sizzle. So I wrote to my friends back home and asked what they use to treat their menopausal symptoms.
但当那种灼烧感击中胸口中心，然后辐射到全身时，简直无法忍受。我学会了准备装满自来水的碗，每次潮热开始时往头上倒。我总是期待水能发出嘶嘶声。所以我写信给家乡的朋友，问她们用什么治疗更年期症状。
They told me about black cohosh, flaxseed, apricots, and berries, but the general consensus was that the most effective treatment was estrogen vaginal cream and hormone replacement therapy. My friends inside prison told me, there's no way you're going to get any of those.
她们告诉我黑升麻、亚麻籽、杏子和浆果，但普遍一致认为最有效的治疗是雌激素阴道乳膏和激素替代疗法。监狱里的朋友告诉我，你根本不可能得到那些。
I went to dreaded medical and tried for three years to get hormone replacement therapy. I finally got a prescription, and the change was instantaneous. It was like a switch turned me back into the old me. My skin cleared up, my hair regained thickness, my mood was lighter, and the brain fog cleared. Best of all, the hot flashes stopped. It was a miracle drug, until the prescription ran out after two months. The doctors would not give me a refill. That was two years ago.
我去了可怕的医务室，试了三年想得到激素替代疗法。我终于得到了处方，变化是立竿见影的。就像一个开关把我变回了原来的我。皮肤变好了，头发恢复了厚度，心情变轻松了，脑雾也消失了。最棒的是，潮热停止了。那是神药，直到两个月后处方用完了。医生拒绝再开。那是两年前的事了。
So here I am, living with all my symptoms, waiting for this phase to pass. The symptoms can last a decade. Studies show Black women experience more hot flashes, longer hot flashes, and longer perimenopause. I learned this from the radio and from a pamphlet about menopause that I asked my lawyer to send me.
所以我就这样，带着所有的症状活着，等待这个阶段过去。症状可以持续十年。研究表明，黑人女性经历的潮热更多、更持久，围绝经期也更长。我是从广播和从我请律师寄给我的关于更年期的小册子上了解到这些的。
When I tried to learn more by ordering books like The Menopause Manifesto, the prison denied the books for being sexually explicit. Meanwhile, I've gotten a few questions from other neighbors about menopause. We're all getting older in here.
当我试图通过订购像《更年期宣言》（The Menopause Manifesto）这样的书来了解更多时，监狱以色情内容为由拒绝了这些书。与此同时，我也收到了其他邻居关于更年期的几个问题。我们大家都在这里变老。
After all these years, I'm not tired of answering questions yet, but I am tired of answering the same questions. I am tired of repeating the same answers. Depo shot is the name of the birth control everyone wants because the guards don't hand out enough pads and tampons. The flu shot will not give you the flu. No, the COVID vaccine didn't have a chip in it. Tampons don't cause cancer. They don't cause infertility.
这些年后，回答问题我还没觉得累，但我累于重复回答同样的问题。Depo针（避孕针）是每个人想要的避孕药名称，因为狱警发的卫生巾和卫生棉条不够。流感疫苗不会让你得流感。不，新冠疫苗里没芯片。卫生棉条不会致癌。它们不会导致不孕。
I thought by 2025, we'd move on to something else. But the girls still aren't getting this information anywhere else. I wish I could put the 10 most asked questions on a flyer and just pass them out. But that's not how it works in here. So I keep writing.
我以为到2025年，我们就能讨论点别的了。但女孩们依然没能在其他任何地方得到这些信息。我真希望我能把10个最常被问的问题印在传单上，直接分发。但这里不是这么运作的。所以我只能继续写。
Kwaneta Harris's story was read by the actor Kecia Lewis. You can see her on Broadway now, in her Tony Award-winning role in the musical, Hell's Kitchen.
关妮塔·哈里斯的故事由演员凯西亚·刘易斯（Kecia Lewis）朗读。你现在可以在百老汇看到她，她在音乐剧《地狱厨房》（Hell's Kitchen）中获得了托尼奖。
We did reach out to the Texas Department of Criminal Justice for comment. They told us that guards are not supposed to be writing disciplinary infractions for notes, unless they are violent or drug-related, and that The Menopause Manifesto is on the approved book list. Also, Kwaneta has moved prisons over the years. In her current one, the mammogram trip isn't as long.
我们确实联系了德克萨斯州刑事司法部征求意见。他们告诉我们，除非涉及暴力或毒品，否则狱警不应该因为纸条记录纪律处分，而且《更年期宣言》在批准书籍名单中。此外，关妮塔多年来搬过不同的监狱。在她目前的监狱里，乳房X光检查之旅没那么长了。
Our story was produced by Diane Wu. You can find more of Kwaneta's writing on her Substack, Write or Die, Raw Dispatches from a Texas Women's Prison.
我们的故事由黛安·吴制作。你可以在关妮塔的Substack专栏《Write or Die, Raw Dispatches from a Texas Women's Prison》中找到更多她的作品。
Act Three, "Ask Harriotte." So earlier in the show, we had a story about how to know when to leave a relationship. This last story is about a woman who wishes she had that problem. And for the second time in today's show, here's Diane Wu.
第三幕，“问哈丽特”（Ask Harriotte）。节目早些时候，我们讲了一个关于如何知道何时结束一段关系的故事。最后一个故事关于一位希望自己有那个问题的女性。今天节目里，这是黛安·吴第二次登场。
Juna's life outside of dating is as busy as a rom-com heroine's. She lives outside Boston, near her family and a ton of beloved friends. She has a job she likes, fills her free time with jujitsu and weightlifting. She can deadlift 370 pounds, which, if you don't know what that means, it's as impressive as it sounds. Juna's dream is to meet someone at the gym, but that hasn't happened yet.
朱娜（Juna）恋爱之外的生活和浪漫喜剧女主角一样忙碌。她住在波士顿郊外，离家人和一大群深爱的朋友很近。她有一份喜欢的工作，业余时间被柔术和举重填满。她能硬拉370磅，如果你不知道这意味着什么，它的震撼程度和听起来一样。朱娜的梦想是在健身房遇见某个人，但这还没发生。
Because a lot of men are very afraid to approach women at the gym, which I totally understand because, obviously, people, a lot of time, don't want to be disturbed in their workouts.
因为很多男人在健身房接近女性时非常害怕，我完全理解，因为显然，人们很多时候不想在锻炼时被打扰。
Yeah.
是的。
But there are people that want to be disturbed-- me-- by a hot man. Anyways.
但确实有人想被打扰——我——被帅哥打扰。总之。
Juna is 29 and has never had a boyfriend-- not for lack of trying. In high school and college, she was a nerdy pianist who didn't really date. But five years ago, she got on the apps. On her first date, she was so nervous that her teeth were chattering as she waited for the guy to arrive. It didn't go great. Very few of them have. Sometimes, it feels like in her friend group, she's the last one standing.
朱娜29岁，从来没交过男朋友——不是不想努力。在高中和大学时，她是个书呆子钢琴手，没怎么约会。但五年前，她开始用约会软件。第一次约会时，她非常紧张，在等对方到时牙齿都在打颤。那次约会不怎么样。后续也没几个好的。有时，她觉得在自己的朋友圈里，她是唯一剩下的一个。
I feel like we've always all been single, like a lot of my best friends. And now they're all in relationships. And that's when I'm like, it's because I'm blind.
我觉得我们好像一直都是单身，我很多最好的朋友都是。而现在她们都恋爱了。那时我就会想，这是因为我瞎了。
Juna's been blind since she was a little kid. She grew up in Albania, moved to Boston when she was five. The way her blindness works is that everything is very, very blurry. She reads on her phone by zooming in a lot and then holding it right up to her face. The friends she's thinking of who've paired off, they're sighted.
朱娜从小就瞎了。她在阿尔巴尼亚长大，5岁时搬到波士顿。她失明的方式是所有东西都非常非常模糊。她通过把手机放大很多倍，然后放在脸前阅读。她想到的那些脱单的朋友都是视力正常的人。
There's no other thing that explains why it's been so difficult for me. I just, like, can't pinpoint another thing that separates me from the other people that I feel like are successful besides being blind.
没有其他事情能解释为什么这对我来说一直这么难。我只是，找不到除了失明之外，能把自己和那些我觉得成功的人区分开来的其他点了。
Juna's like, I think I'm at least average pretty. I think she's pretty. I'm fun to talk to-- also true. What gives? She experiments with putting that she's blind on her dating profile. The number of matches she gets plummets-- it doesn't surprise her. She feels like meeting people in real life is also harder because of things like eye contact, which doesn't come naturally to her.
朱娜想，我觉得我至少长得平平无奇吧。我觉得她很漂亮。我聊天很有趣——这也是事实。怎么回事？她尝试在约会资料上写明自己失明。匹配数量锐减——她并不惊讶。她觉得在现实生活中遇见人也更难，因为眼神交流等事情对她来说不自然。
I will often look at people's mouths because that's what their voice comes from. So I think I'm always, like, 4 inches under eye contact. And sometimes I'll consciously make an effort to look higher than where I want to look. But then I get very uncomfortable because another big insecurity I have is that my eyes make people uncomfortable. And so I kind of feel bad looking at them in the eye. So basically, I've just given up on looking at people's eyes. I'll just look at their mouth.
我经常看人的嘴，因为声音是从那里发出来的。所以我总是觉得，我距离眼神交流差了4英寸。有时我会刻意努力看高一点，看我想看的地方。但我会很不舒服，因为我有另一个很大的不安全感，就是我的眼睛让人感到不舒服。所以我看他们的眼睛会感到抱歉。所以基本上，我放弃看人的眼睛了。我只看他们的嘴。
Juna was sort of resigned to having a bad time of it. But then a couple of years ago, her friend's mom told her, my friend Harriotte is blind, too. You guys should meet. Juna was pretty skeptical at first, but liked Harriotte right away. They're both musicians, both very talkative.
朱娜对自己糟糕的遭遇有点认命了。但几年前，她朋友的妈妈告诉她，“我朋友哈丽特也失明。你们应该见见。”朱娜起初很怀疑，但很快就喜欢上了哈丽特。她们都是音乐家，都很健谈。
But what really stood out to Juna was Harriotte's bountiful love life. She's 78 and has had three husbands and more boyfriends than she can count-- even an affair, which seemed to really impress Juna. Juna has always wanted to ask her, what's your secret? What should I be doing differently? We went over to Harriotte's home one December evening to find out. Her partner, Frank, let us in.
但真正让朱娜印象深刻的是哈丽特的丰富爱情生活。她78岁，有三任丈夫，男朋友数不过来——甚至还有一段婚外情，这似乎真的震撼了朱娜。朱娜一直想问她，“你的秘诀是什么？我应该怎么做才能有所不同？”去年12月的一个晚上，我们去哈丽特家想一探究竟。她的伴侣弗兰克（Frank）开了门。
Hi, Frank.
嗨，弗兰克。
In the kitchen, Juna tells me one of her favorite stories, the story of how Harriotte and Frank met 20 years ago.
在厨房里，朱娜告诉我她最喜欢的故事之一，哈丽特和弗兰克20年前相遇的故事。
Harriotte and Frank met on a red line train. Harriotte was playing recorder, and Frank heard it and was like, can you teach me that song? Right, guys?
哈丽特和弗兰克在红线地铁上相遇。哈丽特在吹竖笛，弗兰克听到了，就问，“你能教我那首歌吗？”对吧，各位？
Yeah, that's how it happened.
是的，就是那样。
He sat down next to me, and he said, I have my recorder with me.
他坐在我身边，说，我也带了竖笛。
Which is crazy. Like, Frank, why did you have your recorder with you?
这太疯狂了。弗兰克，你为什么带竖笛？
I don't know. That was a certain time in my life.
不知道。那是我生命中特定的一段时间。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They played together on the train, exchanged numbers, became friends, and five years into that friendship, started dating. We sit around the kitchen table and get down to business.
他们在火车上一起吹奏，交换了电话号码，成了朋友，在友谊的第五年，开始约会。我们围着餐桌坐下，进入正题。
OK. Shall we begin?
好的。我们要开始了吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
So, Harriotte--
好的，哈丽特——
Yes, ma'am.
在呢，女士。
Juna starts by explaining how her dating life has gone so far-- no real success, her conclusion that blindness is getting in her way.
朱娜先解释了她的约会史——没有任何真正的成功，她的结论是失明阻碍了她。
So in your idea of your life, right, if you think back on your life, have you ever thought to yourself that your vision impacts your dating? Or has it, to you, just not been a related topic?
那么在你的人生构想中，如果你回望一生，你有没有想过你的视力影响了你的约会？还是说，对你来说，这根本就不是相关话题？
Not been a related topic except to share with people all the amazing experiences that I have kinesthetically and otherwise as a blind person.
不是相关话题，除非是和人们分享我作为一个盲人，在动觉和其他方面获得的所有奇妙体验。
Let's say like meeting people in person, right? One thing that I feel like is very difficult is that I can't make eye contact. And I--
比如面对面遇见人，对吧？我觉得很困难的一点是，我无法进行眼神交流。我——
I never could, baby. So I don't know what you're talking about.
我从来没做到过，宝贝。所以我不知道你在说什么。
[LAUGHS] But Harriotte, all, like, the videos on TikTok about how to meet people at the gym and stuff or whatever, is like, the person makes eye contact with you, and then you smile to let them know that you're available to come-- Harriotte's waving her hands. Harriotte, why-- [LAUGHS]
[大笑] 但哈丽特，所有TikTok上关于如何在健身房遇见人的视频什么的，都是说，对方和你对视，然后你微笑让他们知道你有空可以过来——哈丽特在挥手。哈丽特，为什么——[笑声]
No, I just bump into them awkwardly and say, where's the treadmill?
不，我只是笨拙地撞上他们，然后问，“跑步机在哪？”
Oh, yeah. OK, I do that, too, sometimes, but like--
哦，对。好，我有时也会这样，但——
No, but I mean, with panache, you know? With ease, you know? Like, hey, where's the bathroom? Can you walk me over there? Thank you. I'll get it fixed. I'll do it better next time, you know? Whatever. But don't you see? It's like, we're unwilling to be vulnerable. Everybody is.
不，我是说，得有风度，你知道吗？得从容，你知道吗？比如，“嘿，洗手间在哪？能带我过去吗？谢谢。”我会修复的。我下次会做得更好，你知道吗？无所谓。但你没看到吗？这就像，我们不愿展现脆弱。每个人都不愿。
Well, not Harriotte.
好吧，哈丽特除外。
I have no problem. I'll stand up in the subway and say, hey, anybody getting off at X spot? I have to cross over from the A line to the West 4th Street, whatever.
我没问题。我会在地铁上站起来说，“嘿，有人在X点下车吗？我得从A线穿过到西4街那边什么的。”
That's crazy! I have literally been lost for hours because I refused to ask for help. I'm like, I'm going to wander around until I find where to go to avoid asking for help. So-- now Harriotte's laughing at me.
这太疯狂了！我曾因拒绝求助而迷路几个小时。我心想，我要一直转悠直到找到路，以避免求助。所以——现在哈丽特在笑我。
No, not at you. I'm just laughing at the discomfort and awfulness of it, you know?
不，不是笑你。我只是在笑那种不适和糟糕感，你知道吗？
Juna's default mode is to be completely competent in everything she does. She hates being underestimated or condescended to. This is her way of protecting herself from all of that. But talking to Harriotte, she realizes it might come with a downside. Like when Juna's friend invites her to go salsa dancing, even though she wants to try it, she doesn't. She worries the way she dances might look embarrassing.
朱娜的默认模式是在所做的一切中保持完全称职。她讨厌被低估或被居高临下地对待。这是她保护自己不受伤害的方式。但和哈丽特谈话时，她意识到这可能也有缺点。比如当朱娜的朋友邀请她去跳萨尔萨舞时，尽管她想尝试，但她拒绝了。她担心自己跳舞的样子看起来很尴尬。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Do you realize how much you're basing all of your perceptions, at least from where I'm sitting with this, on the sighted world?
你意识到你有多大程度上是基于外界的视角来看待一切的吗，至少从我坐在这里听起来是这样？
But the sighted world is the world, Harriotte. Like--
但 sighted world（视力正常的世界）就是这个世界，哈丽特。就像——
It is, but it hasn't been a problem. I still feel that my world has total integrity.
它是，但它从来没成为问题。我依然觉得我的世界拥有完整性。
I feel like my world has total integrity, too, but I feel like-- I don't know.
我觉得我的世界也有完整性，但我感觉——我不知道。
I think the hardest thing in life, whether you're sighted or anything, is a deeper self-acceptance, really. And that doesn't matter what the hell other people react to or what they think or whatever.
我觉得生活中最困难的事，无论你是 sighted（视力正常）还是什么，都是更深层的自我接纳，真的。那根本不在乎其他人会有什么反应，会怎么想之类。
Whatever you're sensing from me, do you think that that plays a role into why it might be hard for me to date people?
无论你从我身上感觉到什么，你认为这在我难以与人约会中起作用吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK, why?
好的，为什么？
Because you have a lens, you have a filter that is constantly on high that says they're not going to get me. They're going to put me down. They're going to ignore me. They're going to pity me. And if that is sort of in the emotional undercurrent within you, then it'll amplify everything--
因为你有一面透镜，你有一个一直处于高强度的过滤器，上面写着“他们不会理解我。他们会贬低我。他们会忽视我。他们会同情我”。如果这在你内心的情感潜流中存在，那么它会放大一切——
Except yourself. It's hard to know what to do with that kind of advice.
除了你自己。很难知道该怎么处理那样的建议。
What do you think that I should do differently? But you can't say you have to deeply accept yourself because I just don't even know what that means. So it's like--
你觉得我应该怎么做才能有所不同？但你不能说“你必须深刻接纳自己”，因为我根本不知道那意味着什么。所以就像——
OK, that's fine.
好的，没关系。
Harriotte gives her a concrete thing to try. Juna's been taking jiu-jitsu classes that she really loves with mostly guys, and she has a crush on one of them.
哈丽特给她一个具体的东西尝试。朱娜一直在参加柔术课，她很喜欢，大多是男生，她对其中一个人有好感。
Just see if they want to go out and have coffee or tea.
试着看他们想不想出去喝杯咖啡或茶。
I just don't think people do that anymore, Harriotte.
我只是觉得人们现在不再那样做了，哈丽特。
What? So what? Maybe they're all waiting.
什么？那又怎样？也许他们都在等呢。
I don't want to be the one to do it. Why can't they do it?
我不想做迈出第一步的人。为什么不能是他们？
I always make the first move.
我总是迈出第一步。
But Harriotte!
但哈丽特！
Treat it as friendship. It's just a thought.
把它当作友谊。这只是个想法。
No, I think you're right. Like, the guy I have a crush on, for example, me and my friends call him my husband.
不，我觉得你是对的。比如，我暗恋的那个人，我和朋友们叫他“我丈夫”。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, my friend was like, your husband is not in class today. And I'm like, how am I supposed to go talk to my husband? I'm too scared. I'm scared.
比如，我朋友说，“你丈夫今天没来上课。”我就想，“我该怎么去和我丈夫说话？我太害怕了。我好怕。”
No, no, no, you have to reset. Reset.
不，不，不，你必须重置。重置。
So last week, Harriotte, I was in class, and my jiu-jitsu husband usually will ask me to spar once in class. And this time, we only had one spar. Long story short, we didn't get to spar. And I'd only come to class to see my jiu-jitsu husband.
所以上周，哈丽特，我在上课时，我的“柔术丈夫”通常会邀我拆解对练。这次，我们只拆了一次。长话短说，我们没练成。我来上课就是为了看“柔术丈夫”。
And so I saw him on the mat, right? And I was like, I'll go ask him. But I was scared. But I was like, I'll go ask him because he always asks me. I'll go ask him. And I went to go ask him. And he's like a very shy, introverted person. And I asked him. He's like, oh, um, yeah. Actually, I was stretching because I was going to leave, but yeah, I guess we can spar. Yeah.
所以我看到他在垫子上，对吧？我心想，“我要去问他。”但我很害怕。但我心想，“我要去问他，因为他总是问我。我去问他。”我去问他了。他是一个非常害羞、内向的人。我问了他。他说，“噢，嗯，是的。其实，我在拉伸，因为我要走了，但，是的，我想我们可以拆解对练。是的。”
And I was like, oh, no, it's OK. We can do it next time. Yeah, OK. And I ran back to the lockers, and he came up to me. He was like, no, no, no, let's do it. And I was like, no, no, no, it's OK. We can do it another time. He was like, no, let's spar.
我说，“噢，不，没关系。我们下次吧。是的，好的。”我跑回储物柜，他走过来找我。他说，“不，不，不，我们练吧。”我说，“不，不，不，没关系。我们可以改天。”他说，“不，练吧。”
Anyways, it took him, like, three different times to be like, no, let's do it, let's do it, let's do it. And then we did. And I was like, I'm never talking to him again. Like, he can talk to me if he wants, but I am never speaking to him again in class because I was so embarrassed.
总之，他前前后后问了三次，说“练吧，练吧，练吧”。然后我们练了。我心想，“我再也不要和他说话了。”他想跟我说话就说，但我再也不会在课上跟他说话了，因为我太尴尬了。
The fact that he asked you the three times is already not saying I want to be your husband, but it is saying, I would like to do that. So it's authentic. I think he's asking from, just my sense about it, from a very authentic place. And so build on it. Just get to know him. When you finish sparring, you could say, if you would like to go to brunch sometime, just the two of us after jiu-jitsu, let me know.
他问你三次的事实，这还不是在说“我想做你丈夫”，但它是在说“我想做那件事”。所以这是真实的。我觉得他是从一个非常真实的地方请求的。所以顺势而为。只是去了解他。拆解练完后，你可以说，“如果你愿意的话，柔术结束后什么时候一起去吃早午餐，只有我们两个，告诉我。”
[SIGHS] OK.
[叹气] 好的。
So it's been three weeks since you went and talked to Harriotte, and I'm calling to see, are there any updates?
所以，距离你去和哈丽特谈话已经三周了，我打电话想看看，有什么更新吗？
[LAUGHS] Oh, my god, I feel like I'm on one of those dating shows. Anyways, so I went the first time after talking to Harriotte, and I was like, you know what? Let me treat this person the same way I treat everybody else in this class and just be normal and be his friend. And so I started talking to him, and it was like the worst conversation I've ever had in my entire life, not because of me. It was like talking to a brick wall, you guys. It was like--
[笑声] 噢，我的天，感觉我在上那些约会秀节目。总之，和哈丽特谈完后我第一次去上课，我心想，“你知道吗？让我像对待班上其他人一样对待这个人，就正常点，做他的朋友。”于是我开始和他说话，那是我这辈子经历过的最糟糕的对话，不是因为我。你们知道吗，那简直就像对着砖墙说话。简直是——
Huh.
啊。
--so terrible. And I went to the dog park the next day, and I was like, you guys, I think he has literally no personality. And they were like, then why do you like him? And I said, I literally think it's just because of his arms. And I have been so stupid. [LAUGHS]
——太可怕了。第二天我去遛狗，我说，“你们，我觉得他简直完全没个性。”他们说，“那你为什么喜欢他？”我说，“我简直觉得仅仅是因为他的胳膊。我太蠢了。”[笑声]
A very wise person once tweeted, "A crush is just a lack of information," though, for Juna, getting that information-- progress. Juna, determined to follow Harriotte's instructions, actually continued befriending the guy, who ended up being much more fun to talk to later. She still seems a long way from ever making the first move, but now, at least, she knows it's an option.
一个非常明智的人曾经发推文说，“暗恋只是信息缺乏”。不过，对于朱娜来说，获取那些信息——是进步。朱娜决定遵循哈丽特的指示，确实继续和那个人做朋友，结果发现他以后变得好聊多了。她距离迈出第一步似乎还有很长的路要走，但至少，她现在知道这是一个选项。
Diane Wu is a producer on our show.
黛安·吴是我们节目的制片人。
Well, our program today was produced by Tobin Low and edited by Ira Glass. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, and Christopher Swetala. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由托宾·罗（Tobin Low）制作，由艾拉·格拉斯编辑。参与制作今天节目的人员包括菲娅·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、安吉拉·格瓦西、卡西·豪利、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、安东尼·罗曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Susanna Fogel, Susan Burton, Emily Nonko at Empowerment Avenue, David P. O'Neil, Thomas Reid, Evan Ferrante, Derrick Campana, Dashka Slater, Jessica Peters. And thanks to all the people who spoke to us about their breakups caused by a comedian.
特别感谢苏珊娜·福格尔、苏珊·伯顿、Empowerment Avenue的艾米丽·农科、戴维·P·奥尼尔、托马斯·里德、埃文·费兰特、德里克·坎帕纳、达什卡·斯莱特、杰西卡·彼得斯。感谢所有和我们谈论他们因喜剧演员而分手的听众。
One other quick note, we checked the police report about that car accident that Miles told me about at the beginning of the show involving, he said, a Kia Soul. Sorry, Miles. Turns out it was not a Kia Soul. The police report lists it as a Chevy. I don't know make and model. We're going to try to find out for you.
还有一点快速说明，我们查了关于节目开头迈尔斯告诉我的那场涉及起亚Soul的车祸的警方报告。对不起，迈尔斯。结果那不是起亚Soul。警方报告显示是一辆雪佛兰。我不知道品牌和型号。我们会试着为你查出来。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. If you become a This American Life Partner, you'll get bonus content, ad-free listening, and more. In our newest bonus episode, Ira plays two stories that never aired on the show, not because they're bad, but for more interesting reasons, which he explains. To hear it, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。如果你成为《美国生活》的合伙人，你会获得额外内容、无广告收听等等。在我们最新的奖励剧集中，艾拉播放了两个从未在节目中播出的故事，不是因为它们很糟糕，而是出于更有趣的原因，他在节目中解释了。想收听，去thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。链接也在节目介绍里。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's seen Elon Musk's Roman salute and Steve Bannon's, and just has one question--
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。一如既往，特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他见过埃隆·马斯克的罗马式敬礼和史蒂夫·班农的，他只有一个问题——
Are those Nazis real Nazis?
那些纳粹是真的纳粹吗？
I'm David Kestenbaum. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。